when reagan came along the party became  pretty openly racist reagan himself was  a  dedicated racist he wasn't pretending  so he his uh he opened his campaign  as you recall in 1980 in the  philadelphia  mississippi town which is known for only  one thing  civil rights workers were murdered there  the republicans pretended it was an  accident that nobody could miss it  yeah then came the stories about welfare  queens uh  black of course stealing your money and  so on  in fact reagan was so racist that he was  the last  leader in the world to support the  apartheid regime in south africa  at a time when everyone else had left  thatcher  israel everyone reagan was still  supporting it